On a night out while looking for love, there
is nothing like having the support of a friend.
Known sometimes as a wingman or wingwoman,
the term originates from fighter jet pilots,
where the wingman's job is to support and
protect the leading pilot. This same dynamic
is applied when a friend needs support approaching
potential partners. But what is the science
behind this strategy - and do wingmen actually
work?
First things first - you look better in a
group than you do on your own. One study had
participants evaluate pictures of 300 people
and found that faces were significantly more
attractive when they were shown in a group
photo compared to the same faces shown on
their own. Another good tactic a squad can
use is that of a Wild turkey. Wild Turkeys
attract mates in a “coalition” where one
turkey is “dominant” and the other turkey’s
are “helpers”. These helper turkey’s
wear less colourful plumage - making the dominant
one look like a better catch. And this strategy
almost doubles the reproductive success compared
to those turkeys who ride solo.
Even male fireflies work together to attract
ladies! Fireflies use bioluminescent flashes
to signal a mate. And when male fireflies
synchronize their flashes, females responded
82% of the time, compared to 3% of the time
with asynchronous flashes. So maybe it’s
time for your squad to think of a co-ordinated
dance?
Especially if you’re the wingman to a lance-tailed
manakin. Males of this species team up in
pairs, performing intricate dances - including
leaping over one another. But within the group
there is an alpha and a beta - and the beta
never gets lucky. So why be a wingman? A study
that tracked and analyzed DNA of 457 birds
found that beta birds, after learning from
the Alpha’s, had a better chance of becoming
an alpha the following year.
These strategies are often used among males
- but what about females? Across cultures,
human women tend to be more selective or choosy
than men when it comes to partnerships though
significant variation does exists among sexes.
After all, females expend more resources in
pregnancy, making it important that they choose
a partner more selectively. When asked to
describe their courtship strategies, interestingly,
women were actually more likely to use cooperative
techniques than men, but these techniques
were used to avoid partners where there was
no romantic interest. Again this certainly
varies from person to person, and these studies
also only focused on heterosexual behaviour.
How far will your squad go for you? Are they
willing to lie? It turns out the closer relationship
you have with someone the more likely you
are to lie to make them look good. This is
why going out with your best friends to the
bar can help boost your image.
Looking for love or a fling while in the company
of friends is fun and often effective. Just
remember that finding romance doesn’t need
to be a strategic game where you have to “trick”
someone - if you just be yourself you are
more likely to find someone who likes you
for you.
Special thanks to audible for supporting this
episode to give you a free 30 day trial at
audible.com/asap. This week we wanted to recommend
the book “The Invention of Nature”’
by Andrea Wulf, which is a fascinating investigation
of the relationship between environments around
the world and their connectedness with humanity!
You can get a free 30 day trial at audible.com/asap
and choose from a massive selection! We love
them as they are great when you’re on the
go.
And subscribe for more weekly science videos!